all right daniel you're up buddy
hey reg thanks for having me on yeah i
was shaking
well not much right now but i did read
your book
and this is one of the biggest questions
i have from it
because you speak about you know if
something's not working out
or if you reach a certain level and you
won't you have to increase your own
value
you got to make friends it's kind of
like you say if five
of your friends are losers you'll be the
sixth one
so my question is how do you let those
people go
especially if they haven't really
crossed any boundaries
or anything they're just kind of not as
on fire as you are to succeed yeah yeah
so
it's pretty simple right i mean if
you're the smartest guy in the room you
get out of that room
so the guys that you've surrounded
yourself with that
aren't um people that you want to be
around you just leave that room you know
you don't hang out with them you don't
go to the social events when they text
you you're busy
um i mean if you want to be clear about
it and say hey look guys you know like
i'm i'm really busy working on this
project it's really important to me that
i get this business off the ground
i don't have time to sit around and
drink beers in bob's garage on wednesday
night anymore
um i'll be insert whatever on that night
so
okay a simple push away now when it
comes to women
it might maybe if i like share what
happened to me so i had three girls i
was
with at the same time okay and one of
them i just kind of sat aside
but then here i am working on a saturday
and she shows up to my house
you have another conversation send her
away send her her away
don't answer calls don't answer nothing
two weeks go by here she is at your
house again
how do you handle that situation she
just
so she's basically obsessed with you
yeah she like
my friends tell me oh she's a stalker
you know which is
well not too far from the tree but
okay so if she poses a danger then you
should contact the police
yeah but she doesn't well you know you
don't
know what she's done but i mean if she's
basically like showing up at your
property she's not getting the hint that
it's so like
i mean i mean the thing you got to
understand about women is they hate
being dumped
right like there's there's always a levy
and a leave or
in the equation and women hate being the
person that gets left
when you dump a woman they want to have
endless meetings with you they'll
continuously text you
they want to send emails they want to
get clarity
if you go and try to do the same thing
as a guy then you're [ __ ]
branded as a a simp or a stalker
right and they'll go and file a
restraining order on you so
just just drop the hammer and say look
we're done
the time between us is finished right
now so
you just need to move on and if you
carry on harassing me showing up at work
coming to my house i'm gonna have to
file a restraining order you know it's
as simple as that
and if she does it again then you file
it
so just straight down yeah dude
yeah like you can't have time for these
like obsessive
like women that that like they're the
ones that will show up at your house at
four o'clock in the morning
and like drug you and cut off your body
parts like they do weird [ __ ] dude like
you
you don't know what you're dealing with
here
okay well i appreciate the advice in
case it escalates to a point of it
becoming a problem
i would i would state your intent
clearly and if it has to be done in
in uh written format like via text um
at least you got evidence that you can
show the police and then if it
carries on then you file that order with
the police but uh
aside from that it should just be like
hey go away we're done
yeah that's what i was thinking like no
thank you
yeah enjoy your life done hey dan can i
see you on thursday night
i'm busy thursday night for the rest of
my life go away yeah
awesome well all right thank you and
thanks for writing an awesome book
you got it man and hey if you haven't
had a chance yet leave a review on
amazon i
totally appreciate hearing what your
views are i read all those reviews
thanks man awesome bye
you